there clearly is a narrative out there
that taliban are winning in fact they
are
propagating an inevitable victory on
their behalf they're dominating a lot of
the airwaves
on that sort of thing i would tell you
that as of today
uh more or less i guess it's about 212
213 it's in that range two hundreds
of the district centers are in taliban
control it's about half of the 419 that
are out there
uh you've got 34 provincial capitals in
afghanistan
none of them have been seized as of
today
by the taliban although the taliban is
putting pressure on the outskirts
of probably about half of them 17 of
them in fact
and what they're trying to do is isolate
the major population centers
they're trying to do the same thing uh
to kabul uh
and roughly speaking order of magnitude
a significant amount of territory has
been seized
over the course of six eight ten months
sort of thing by the by the taliban so
momentum
appears to be strategic momentum appears
to be sort of with the taliban
the afghan security forces are
consolidating their forces
so part of this is they're giving up
district centers in order to consolidate
their forces because they're taking an
approach to protect the population
and most of the population lives in the
provincial capitals in the capital city
of kabul
so they are right now as we speak
adjusting forces
to consolidate into the provincial
capitals in kabul